hey hey hey
I've done the seven day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded All my
expectations alhamdulillah I was worried
that was an overrated product that's
what he fought until he tried it what
was the system you can build a habit
with the Quran by seven day free trial
promises no credit card details required
at all and you decide for yourself is it
overrated or is it underrated go to the
link in the description box below Brown
assistance Andrew Tate was being
transferred to the courts or to the
prison or whatever I don't know and he
was seen holding a Quran this hunt Now
by looking at that I highly doubt he
knew that a Paparazzi would be able to
take a picture of that one that shows me
is sincerity brothers and sisters and
the fact that man who's as wealthy as
him the fact that the only thing that
they granted him they allowed him to
have and the only thing that he could
take with him was the Quran
think about that brothers and sisters
going into prison and they will grant
you the Quran it's your right to read
this if you're a religious person you're
a Muslim or Christian Bible whatever it
may be they are going to grant you that
and that is the one thing that you would
need but guidance from your lord now
what about when we buy brothers and
sisters Allah says in the Quran
brothers and sisters when we enter that
grief Allah says you are busy with the
world EFS until you visit the graves and
no surely you're going to know and no
you will surely know brothers and
sisters when you enter that when you
enter that grave it will be the Quran
that you take with you the Quran that
you lived by the Quran that you read the
Quran that benefited you the Quran that
told you to spend on the poor to take
care of the orphan the needy to be good
to your parents to worship Allah that
Quran will be benefiting you in your
grave as well as if you enter the prison
brothers and sisters do not wait
for the last moments of your life to
turn to the Quran for Andrew Tate to be
holding on to it in his most difficult
time maybe for him brothers and sisters
when we die it is this book this Quran
is kanam of Allah that is going to
benefit us and I will end on the squad
Amber Allah said then we granted the
book to those who we have chosen from
our servants some of them wrong
themselves some of them follow middle
course and some of them for more uh
foremost in Good Deeds by Allah's will
that is truly the greatest Bounty
meaning that Allah is putting three
people into this category the ones that
wrong themselves Allah saying they are
still the ones that inherit the book
meaning those who still they try to
practice they read the Quran they trip
up they make sins they are still the
ones inheritable those who are mediocre
those who do their fart the things that
you know that should be done Etc yeah
and they fall short for the sins Etc and
some scores even said it's maybe this
one but still those are the ones who
pray the Salah and Etc but they fall
through sin these are the ones who try
to abstain from sins as much as possible
and those who Excel each other by doing
the extra fast extra
good deeds foremost runners
so look at how Allah has even inherited
it to the ones that even run themselves
brothers and sisters that is People Like
Us me and you in one tough Syria that I
said the eyeshadow and has said these
ones who wronged themselves they are
talking about us subhanallah look how
humble our mother is
till next time brothers and sisters
the Quran
foreign